LA SAISON DERNIÈRE À GOLDEN MOUSTACHE !
ON A RI !
Ah ah ah ah !
Une huître ?
Ah ah ah !
non....
ON A PLEURÉ...
Toi t'as le sida.
Quoi ?!
ON A CRIÉ...
Voilà !!!
Allez hop !!!
paaa !!!!!
Rhaaaa !!!!!!!!!!
Ahhhhhhhh !!!!!
Putain !!!
ON A DANSÉ...
ON A CHANTÉ...
J'ai mis mon sexe
Il a mis son quoi ?
dans un tupperware
ON A......
ON A....
J'vais le défoncer.
DE LA BAGARRE
Ahhhhhhhhhh !!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
DE L'AMOUR
Je suis homosexuel.
Ah bon ?
DE L'ACTION
Où est-ce qu'il est passé ?
J'ai perdu mon singe dans le coin
donc je pense......
euh.....
vu que votre plan est assez large ben je me dit que
vous l'avez peut être vu.....
passer quelque part
Ouais
non.....
AH ! QUEL REBELLE CE MICHEL
Le service était top ! Nickel !
Y'avait quand même quelques employés....euh....
euh....
hein ?
Y'AURA PAS UN NINJA QUI A INFILTRÉ LE GOUVERNEMENT
ouécénsir !!!!!!!!!
CA NE VEUT RIEN DIRE....
DU COUP IL Y'AURA UN MEC AVEC UN GROS NEZ
Si mais discret quoi....
Alors c'est un chimpanzé...
un petit chimpanzé.
EN GROS, IL Y'AURA PLEIN DE TRUCS.
IL Y'AURA PAS PLEIN D'AUTRES TRUCS.
MAIS COMME LES TRUCS QU'IL Y AURA PAS
SONT MOINS BIEN QUE LES TRUCS QU'IL Y AURA
ET BEN.......
ON ESPÈRE QUE CA VOUS PLAIRA
JE SUIS CREVÉ.